herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
heute zusammen mit kelly cam ist hätte
sie nicht sie kelly ok müsste ich harry
potter ist geweckt werden wir spielen
heute ein harry potter frist ich mir ja
im griff in der kritik kelly hat den
kinostart am start und ich habe letztens
bei sturm ihr ein video gesehen ist
verlinkt ich mich auch als auch mal aber
unter dem video was gerade mit kelly
aufgenommen habe das ist nämlich auch
ein gewisses genau da haben die beiden
butter mir gemacht und ich dachte okay
kelly ist ja eigentlich voll der potter
die regale reporter tattoo haben hilft
oder schadet die hat hält zauberstäbe
und liebe filme ich hab' ich sagen sogar
felix beliebt
deshalb habe ich mir gedacht ich muss
mich mit kelly messen ich muss gegen
chris machen und dann machen wir das ist
kein spaß leute wir sind jetzt gerade so
auch vor sich und so aber das ist
absoluter ernst huberty mordes anklagen
zum warmmachen machen wir erstmal bis
zusammen runde harry potter christi auf
der seite von karl sind haben wir eins
gefunden
harry potter ist tot es zauberer mit
google talk mutter nicht nach
das skript haben dass meine peter mucke
görig und weiter richtig hat das nie
gegeben aber kam war cool is safe dass
man ja landrat vor dem entweder das
prüfen könnte aber weich und schwierig
metzger streit und ich glaube dass hier
nicht gewünscht das klingt so aus wo
arbeitet macht weiter hauptkirche in der
kleinen für mich braucht und mogelte
packten den herzen aller weiteren
zusammenarbeit unterbreiten ist jedoch
nicht haben ich weiß es und 23 vermieten
gibt es dann nochmal diese die
kreisschau dieser brief wie sie sagte ja
stimmen was braun harry hermine und ron
empfohlen wird der contest radl sehen
alle diese gewinne gemacht war zu schwer
was tut also die wähler auch die brüssel
mitbringen der fed von mir gehts runter
gespielt und er wurde auch zusammen das
sind ja diese wunderschönen frauen die
für jeden unterschiedlich aussehen um
das autogramm ist nicht nein ich weiß
nur dass der in jamaika also irgendwie
so eine story erfindet er sagt dann
würde ich arbeitet sind da und waren
überhaupt nicht mehr an sich sind ist
eine andere buch ja war das ist schon
schwer lag dann auch die brüstung
also ich glaube dir sehen ihn so ich
möchte sehen hier aber am waldrand immer
ganz kurz
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also entweder einspringen oder der feld
und körperhaltung der kennt ehrlich der
ist schon ohnmacht stupa und ich glaub
ich glaube nicht es war heiß erklärte
auf die brüstung wird springen abrüstung
von dem credit stadion
die kommen noch am ende des spiels
entsprechend staaten überhaupt nicht
reagieren haben wir solche die kobolde
tja und dafür gegangen diese velasco
aber das war schon mal war schon mal
ordentlich die fragen in echt schwer ja
die leute gedacht waren gerade schweren
sagen da sind jetzt glaube ich eine ja
aber jetzt jetzt jetzt geht's richtig
los wir haben dass ich ein besonders
schweres quiz gefunden dass wir jetzt
gegeneinander spielen wollte ultimative
herrschaft in klammern ist schwer
verliebt das machen wir jetzt nicht
aufzeichnen und dazu kollegen wie man
will
okay das sind 35 jahren die gleichen
fragen jetzt die gebühren beide die
gleiche wand deshalb ist es richtig
spannend so alles gegen mich zu
verlieren war und nicht so jetzt ein
ganzes leben
change einsatz wenn ich gewinne weil
halt alles klar dann will ich sein die -
wohl findet harry im ersten produkt in
seinem stand ein paar socken zum
anziehen was eine frage auf einem karton
unter dem bett im regal er hat doch
schon welcher an bord was aber eben nur
die geben oder das ist noch stay close
und niedersachsen im ersten und aber
bestimmt ganz am anfang des weges
2 was findet harry im zweiten buch
im handschuhfach ist sogar ich habe
meine antwort getätigt so scheiße mann
das ist mega städte sind so dick heißt
im super unwichtig für mich was dabei zu
finden wird ist doch nix mit dem verlauf
der story ist und ich was macht onkel
vernon nachdem harry von seinem traum
von einem fliegenden motorrad erzählt
kelly ist ein bisschen helfen die sonne
blendet mich hier so wäre das ding ist
ich habe kennst du diese illustrierten
bücher die er so endlich mal sein
davon hat für die ersten drei teile
gekauft und habe auch schon ersten teil
wieder anfangen zu leben und da kam das
vor als wenn dann nur bilder sondern es
kann man da auch lesen und mir das
original text und die charaktere sind so
gezeichnet wie sie bestehen werden
[Musik]
da wir somit schneit mit den großen geil
was man sie werden schnell von seinem
traum vom fliegen motorrad erzählt ganz
kurz wusstest du dass ist der
verschwörungstheorie ich hab das mal
harry marx ist dass die das ist deswegen
so löser waren weil um den ort herum
wird man
der harry potter random wisse ja gut
verschwörung und im ersten teil wird
mann der kurz durch den tagesablauf von
onkel vernon mitgenommen er ist ja noch
ein mega hat vielleicht ist dann nur
weil er jahrelang elf jahren mit einem
box zusammen er aber am ersten tag
gehören ich da wird ja schon seit tagen
doch geschrieben das in deutschland
entwickelte ist eine galeone wer weiß
ich gar nicht
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher aber
sicherlich etwas langweiliges klare
glaube ich auch nicht
ich habe mich am besten weg durch das
verspricht spannung nicht aushalten ich
wusste er ist rudi die gruppe um fünfte
steuern bei der reise zum mord platz
zwölf erste möglichkeit doch gar nicht
mit diese verwöhnten beantworten ich
weiß alles harmonie die gruppe
unterkommen buch steuern
[Musik]
ist doch der der tal wo dir wo die macht
uns ins zimmer gekommen
von genau die holen den armstrong ist
zum ersten mal dabei
der orden des phönix wäre dann das erste
mal so hier
ich habe jetzt einfach mal eine antwort
auf ihre frage mich erinnern zu können
ok nächste frage untervaz leidet harry
nach einem unterricht bei meta muri im
vierten buch schnecken spucken dauert
sicher nasenbluten oder ohren zucken war
glaube ich muss mich okay ich habe mich
entschieden wie viel zeit haben die vier
champions aus solchen besuch bei der
zweiten aufgabe und diese zu lösen
welcher name steht in dem zaubertränke
buch welches sich harry im sechsten buch
von rom aus leiten zu zeigen
hundertwasser rupert sommer vorstellte
war schwer
also ich glaube ich weiß ich glaub ich
auch was für süßigkeiten natur wilder
wein im sechsten buch mit liebe gefüllt
um harry rumzukriegen karte buchen schon
falsche seite betonen oder schoko hessen
agah egal ob wo hält professor lupin
seinem unterricht zum thema ihr wichtel
im dritten buch im nebenzimmer in der
großen halle auf den quidditch feld
verteidigung gegen die dunklen künste
klassen leute die haben bisschen an der
kamera rumgespielt und hoffe dass ich
jetzt ein bisschen besser ist ja dann
sind sie einmal die antwort
wo hält professor libyen seien
unterrichtete ich habe mich nun soll
harry lattek mit der eule für den tages
propheten im
alters durch diese frage oder nein
um wie viel uhr fährt der hogwarts
express und kings cross los letzte frage
vor der auswertung was damit an der kür
von im haus von vollmers content 6
was also haben wir als erstes sagen muss
scheiße und verwirrt
die p 0 gibt die note annehmen
die haben neun von 13 richtig
beantworten
im durchschnitt haben die nutzer 8,47
richtige laut markit und schauen wir uns
neuen richtige ich hatte sechs richtige
das war heute schrecklich
du musst die bücher wohl noch einmal
leben beim nächsten mal wird es
vielleicht besser
[Musik]
ich hatte die ganze zeit sowie fordern
dass du das mit besiegen würde ich das
ding ist es ein kompletter zu halten
sich ganz ehrlich sagen weil ich wusste
eigentlich gar nicht aber durch fan ein
paar sachen lustig schon okay leute da
machen wir schon cool ist es am hang mit
den zauberstäben so dass beim nächsten
video wieder bis dahin tschüss